i want to attempt fate but clearly the
negotiations about uh all our difficult
concert cases have been going on uh for
a long time and really i think it would
not be sensible for me to to comment
until uh we've we've got a final result
and i think that uh conversations are
still going on um
are we about to or have we paid off the
400 million pounds historic debt uh
written off the historic debt to iran is
any of this issue on your conscience
i think that it's very important when
you've got
quite delicate
discussions going on negotiations going
on
in tehran about some of our most
difficult consular cases particularly
nazanin zagori ratcliffe
that you know we should say as little as
possible until
and unless and until the thing is
actually concluded and everybody wants
uh nazanin home uh uh we've been working
on that for a long long time i do not
want to
do anything to to interrupt the
conversations right now um you're
heading to saudi arabia to see uh
mohammed bin salman you're famously
close to him you text him you chat with
him you're much closer to him than the
biden administration what what do you
want from him and the saudi arabian
government and do you hope he will
listen
i think that we've got a
global crisis in which it's obvious that
uh
the russian aggression in ukraine has
helped to trigger a
spike in the price of hydrocarbons
spiking the price of oil and it is vital
if we're going to stand up to putin's
bullying if we're going to avoid being
blackmailed by putin in the way that so
many western countries sadly have been
we've got to get ourselves off russian
hydrocarbons they're a massive part of
the global market for hydrocarbons they
help to drive the price uh we need to
talk to other producers around the world
about how we can move away from that
dependency
vladimir putin over the last years has
been like a pusher uh feeding an
addiction
in uh western countries to his
hydrocarbons to his oil and gas
we need to to get ourselves off that
addiction um
saudi arabia have just executed 81
people at the weekend
um alongside that you've got u.s
intelligence that suggests
that
mbs the person that you're going to see
was
behind the murder of jamal khashoggi
iran
may be having historic debts written off
it's quite a good time to be a
repressive regime right now isn't it
i think that what the world is seeing is
the return in ukraine to the kind of
brutality the kind of
absolutely indiscriminate bombing of
civilian
centers of
great cities that we last saw in the
european continent 80 years ago
this is quite unbelievable what is
happening now in uh in our continent
and we need to make sure that we build
the strongest widest possible uh
coalition uh to ensure
that vladimir putin does not succeed
that we wean ourselves off uh russian
hydrocarbons and that's what the uk is
is helping to do but a coalition with
other unpleasant regimes prime minister
well those are your words uh sam what we
want to do is build the widest it's
clear that iran and saudi arabia are not
important
now i didn't say that but we want to we
want to build the widest possible uh
coalition uh to ensure
that we we focus on what is happening in
uh ukraine the effect that that is
happening that is having on the price of
oil and gas there's no question at all
that the spike in oil and gas which is
being felt by british consumers by
everybody who uh has a a central heating
system everybody in this country is
seeing the effects of uh that that spike
in in prices we have to deal with that
in any way that we can and and what we
need to do is build long-term security
of energy supply in this country that's
what we're doing we're setting out a
strategy
for long-term energy security in the uk
but part of that
in the short term is is making sure that
we are not
as dependent in the west as we currently
are
on russian oil and gas the uk is
fortunate in that
we only take three percent of our of our
gas
from russia a lot more of our diesel
comes from russia we're going to have to
make sure that other producers are
are doing what they can and we're going
to have to help the whole world to move
forward with greener solutions with
green technology so that ultimately were
not dependent on on vladimir putin and
it's an absolutely crucial thing if
we're not going to be black belt by
putin we have to take these steps but
prime minister the treasury is making
huge sums billions in vat receipts from
higher petrol and diesel prices in
france they're
putting 2.2 billion dollars into a fuel
rebate to cut 15 euro cents off the
price of a litre do you think something
like that could work here we've frozen
field fuel duty for about 12 years
already uh sam and i think we put about
21 billion pounds so far into supporting
uh people through the through the uh the
the uh
price bikes that we're seeing and
9.1 billion pounds going alone just to
helping people with their own their
energy costs but long-term uh and medium
term what you've got to do is ensure
that we have greater security of supply
here in the uk that we take back control
of our of our energy supplies we make
sure we don't abandon our own
hydrocarbons here in the uk but also uh
double down on wind power double down on
solar and and help the whole world to be
less dependent on putin's hydrocarbons
and that can be achieved and listen to
what all the other european countries
are now saying three weeks ago they
wouldn't have said that was possible uh
a month ago before the invasion
everybody was saying oh no we'll never
be able to do it now after what putin
has done in ukraine you're seeing
european colleagues step up to the plate
and say right this is the time we've got
to learn our lesson
as the west we've got to end that
dependency on russian hydrocarbons and
that's one of the reasons i'm going out
to the gulf